Nebojte mi nicí projít tato tréninová pravidla, abyste viděli, jakých parametrů se bude tento kus pohybovat.
To je na stráně... ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,
Nejsou to předsevzetí nebo přikázání.
jsou to nutná pravidla, aby se rozvinuli základní... jsou to nutná pravidla k meditaci.
Obsláště v tomto kurzu.
Neníčit anebo zraňovat živé bytosti.
To bylo první pravidlo, takže v době tohoto kurzu se zdáme zabíjení živých bytostí.
Na sebe navzájem.
Nebrat to, co mně není dáváno.
Takže už jsme o tom měli mluvit od Bante.
Ale musíme také zavolat vzpomínky od druhého.
Takže to vytváří velmi bezpečnou atmosféru.
To další je,
Neodávat se smyslným a romantickým činům ani živený myšlenek na ně.
Potřebujeme všechnu energii, kterou sebereme, abychom ji praktikovali a oslobodili se.
Nepoužívat zraňující nebo nepravdivou mluvu.
To je snadné, protože dodržujeme absolutní mlčení.
Některý je, nezabíjící substancí, které zemří mysl.
Nevyžívat žádné omámné látky, které zatemňují mysl.
Takže i moc silný kafe.
Kafe je silný.
Mysl je příliš zamyslná.
Takže nezabíjící.
Některý je, nezabíjící.
Nepřejídat se.
Dívat se na jídlo, jako by to byl lék pro tělo.
Jak říkal Bante, my nepotřebujeme černí jídlo, protože nic neděláme.
Tak klidně a prokázíme se pomoci.
Ale je v tom také dobrý důvod, protože ze zvyku se můžeme cítit hladovní.
Toto je pro mě dobrý okamžik, jak si napojit se nebo spojit se s lidmi ve světě, kteří jsou hladovní.
V naší společnosti je to velmi vzácné cítit se hladovní.
Takže když si můžu dostat biskut, bude to biskut pro speciální exercice.
Když si můžu dostat biskut, bude to biskut pro speciální exercice.
Takže když si můžu dostat biskut,
Já vás uvedu do tajemství toho, jak vám může Sušenka pomoct k absolutnímu osvobození.
The next one is not to oversleep.
Ne spát víc, než je nutné.
You may know that we sleep in one and three quarter hour rhythms.
Možná, že víte, že spíme k rytmu jedné a tři čtvrtě hodiny.
Obvykle tři nebo čtyři tyhle cykly dají sedm hodin.
Sedm hodin je pro lidské bytosti.
Osm hodin je pro psy.
Takže sedm hodin tuto noc, protože někteří z vás jsou možná unavení, takže budeme spát sedm hodin.
Když budete mít dobrý spádek, tak musíme začít zjistit,
Jestli že budete mít dostatek spánku, tak bude moct během dne rozpoznat rozdíl mezi skutečnou únavou a takovou otupělostí.
A navíc je tu taková chvíle po obědě,
si můžeme dát takový posilující šlofík.
Ale není to nutné.
Chceme, abyste se cítili věnit.
Po celodenní meditaci nebudeme příliš unavení, takže můžeme spát 5 a půl na 6 hodin.
Proto budeme vstávat trochu dříve.
Bude to stát trošku úsilí pozvednout energii.
A po třech dnech si uvědomíte, že jste v životě spali příliš mnoho.
Neoddávat se marným rozptílením.
Já toto ještě rozvedu pak během hovoru večer, ale znamená to v podstatě nic nečíst nebo nepsat.
Musíme zavřít přemýšlející mysl.
Zvlášť čtení a psaní.
Jestliže si někteří z vás vedete denník, tak možná je ta dobrá praxe na konci dnes si napsat pár poznámek.
Ale jestliže začnete psát knihu, tak to je špatné znamení.
Neoddávat se sebe zkrašlování.
To je veliká uliva, že se nemusíme starat o to, jestli jsme krásní.
Nebo ještě oškliví.
Takže pro nás únava, upravenost, čistota musí být oddělená od starosti o krásu.
A posledně, když se očekáváme nového světa,
uchovávat a opatrovat ušlechtilé mlčení.
Chceme proskoumat tento
psychofyzický organismus.
Já rád, líbí se mi to říct takto, psychofyzický organismus.
Aby jsme to mohli udělat, tak musíme zastavit ty vstupy, které k nám přichází.
Takže tohle je důvod, proč nesmíme sdílet.
Můžeme se trochu podívat na kontrolu, ale nebyt příliš způsobený.
Jsme intensivní.
Jsme záležitý na... Jsme záležitý na... Jsme záležitý na... investigování.
Jde nám o to, proskoumat tu vnitřní krajinu.
V angličtině rozdílíme za landscape a inscape, taková řečka.
Takže čím více se můžeme odpočítat přes naše vidění a slyšení, nejvíc slyšení, ale vidění, protože vidění vždy vytvoří nás, tak dostaneme mnohem důležitější silu.
Takže když zastavíme přísun informací přes slyšení a hlavně vidění, tak můžeme dosáhnout hlubšího vnitřního ticha.
A jedna z velmi rušivých
Věcí pro někoho, kdo toho chce dosáhnout, je komunikovat s někým druhým.
A jestliže se podíváte někomu do očí, tak už vlastně dostáváte nějakou, už vzniká komunikace.
Tak proto je dobré mít oči sklopené a držet se jaksi sobě.
Kdo dělá tuto meditaci velmi dobře, působí trochu depresivně.
Ale to je jenom vzhled.
Opatrovat.
Další věcí je snažit se dodržet ten rozpis nejlépe, jak umíme.
Tento kurz je
Je to někud náročný, takže kdyby se vám to zdálo příliš, tak přijďte za mnou a popovídáme si.
Někdy přicházejí silné emoce.
Lidé si myslí, že jsi zblázný.
Udítejte a přijďte za mnou.
Někdy je to dobré vynechat sezení.
Potřebujete svobodnou možnost jít.
Nechajte na této závodě.
Pojďte za hodinou v této závodě.
Tam jsou krásné závody a závody.
Nechajte na závodě, je to těžké.
Když jdou na závodě, můžou se tam mít mnoho lidí?
Určitě mnohem méně než tady.
Pokud můžete, zůstaňte na území tohoto hotelu.
Znovu je to o tom, nechat ty brány zavřené, to vnímají.
Ale pokud si myslíte, že je to příliš těžké, pak zavření,
Jestli se cítíte příliš jaksi sevření, stažení, tak se klidně projděte, ale znovu v klidu a meditativní.
Obzvlášť ti z vás, kteří jsou začátečníci.
Ty, kteří už praktikují dlouho, myslím, že je zakázat opouštět hotel.
To je asi k těm tréninkovým pravidlům a já vždy začínám ten kurz s touto pužou.
Kdyby se připojí, tak je to správná 2021.
Takže první je buddhan pujemi, dhaman pujemi, sanghan pujemi.
A ti, kteří to dělají, bavujeme.
Takže bavování... Promiňte, dhaman pujemi, a někteří z nás bavujeme.
Bavování je velmi silný bodylanguž pro odstranění.
Klanění je velmi silný projev těla při pokoru.
Duchovní život
Protože duchovní život nám vždycky řekne, co máme dělat.
Je to proti těm běžným touhám já.
Takže když malý chlapec říká, že jsi potřebuje nějaké slušnosti,
Ten malý vlásik říká, že bychom si měli jít spát, tak ten duchovní život nám říká, probud se.
Ten malý vlásik říká, potřebuješ ještě jeden kousek dortu,
Tak duchovní život říká nech toho.
Takže to klanění je velmi silný jazyk těla, můžete se klanit z důvodu úcty a vděku.
Při tom kurze dlužby, abychom se v té praxi odezdali.
Ta druhá část je podsta učiteli.
Pálý vyslouhujete prakticky stejně, jako když to čtete.
Potom vezmeme trojí útočiště.
Dhammam saranam gacchami Sangham saranam gacchami Potom to způsobíme do dhyampi, buddham, atd.
do dhyampi, buddham, saranam, atd.
Takže pro lidi, kteří byli vytvořeni jako buddháci, buddha je samozřejmě historická věc.
Pro lidi, kteří jsou buddhisté, buddha je zároveň historická věc.
Je tu přirozená víra v buddhu a jeho učení.
Ale pro nás meditující je důležitější rozpoznat, že buddha je také v nás.
Naším smyslem, cílem je uvědomit si buddhu v nás.
My musíme na začátku
uvěřit, že je v nás něco, co nás osvobodí.
Dhamma je celé učení.
Je celé učení.
Není problém se znovuzrozováním a budoucími životy.
Ale pro nás jako meditující je
je důležité víra v tuto praxi.
Toto je dharma?
Toto je dharma.
Pro lidi, kteří rostli v buddhismu,
tak je sangha skupinou lidí, kteří dosáhli nivány.
Pro nás meditující jsme sangha my sami, skupina, kteří jsme tady lidi.
Potřebujeme druhé lidi.
Takže když přijmeme útočiště, tak je to naším porozuměním.
Když to přijmete,
tak to můžete... nemusíte se k tomu připojit, když nechcete.
Ale jestliže se to nechcete při tom obřadu přijmout, tak alespoň jaksi mějte takovou úctu k tomu kurzu.
Když to uděláme, to nesmíš být buddhistem.
To bude proti celému postmodernímu hnutí.
Tak to uděláme.
A potom Tóni bude mluvit.
A pak budeme číst společně vypásané getá.
A pak Tony má nějaké verše, které přečte.
A předtím, než řekneme sádu, sádu, sádu, jen jeden moment pro vás, aby si silně se vytvořil.
Tak to bude chvíle pro vás, když se odezdat v praxi.
A odeznejte se na těch šest, sedm dnů.
Potom, že čtu ty deset
tréninkový předsedcetí, prosím opakovat po mně.
Flamen je univerználným duchovním symbolem.
Světl je cesta porozumění.
Teplo je láska a soucit.
Ta pohybná energie je činem.
To vše je v osmi dílném stresce.
Takže můžeme začít.
Bodhán půjde, dháman půjde, svangán půjde,
Namo tassa bhavato arhato sama sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhavato arhato sama sambuddhasa Namo tassa bhavato arhato sama sambuddhasa
bodham sarvanam gacchami, dhammam sarvanam gacchami, sangham sarvanam gacchami, tuty ampe bodham sarvanam gacchami,
Dutiyam vidam man saranam gacchami Dutiyam vid sangam saranam gacchami Tatiyam vid buddham saranam gacchami Tatiyam vidam man saranam gacchami
Tati Ampi Sangam Sarvam Gacchami Já přijímám nasledující pravidla, které budu během kurzu dodržovat.
Neníčit anebo zraňovat živé bytosti.
Nevrat to, co mě není dáváno.
Neoddávat se smyslným a romantickým činům ani živení myšlenek na ně.
Nepoužívat zraňující a nebo nepravdivou mluvu.
Nepoužívat žádné omámě látky, které zatemnují mysl.
Nepřejídat se.
Nespát víc, než je nutné.
Neoddávat se marným rozptílením.
Neoddávat se maným rozptýlením.
Neoddávat se sebezkrašlováním.
Uchovávat a opatrovat ušlechtilé mlčení.
Existuje to, co není zrozené.
co neumírá, co není stvořené a není podmíněné.
Utočičtě, přistav a domov, dokonala spokojenost a klid.
Jako oceán má jenom jedno hůď a to slanou, tak nibana má jenom jedno hůď.
První, musíme představit, že pasana a vrstva jsou samotné.
Takže tyto věci nám říkají, co to je.
Musíme to zjistit.
Takže můžeme tyto věci sdílet spolu.
Divipasana, gata.
Ano, můžeš to představit?
Můžeš to představit?
Všechny podmíněné věci jsou nestálené.
Když je toto umožňováno, člověk se obrostí od toho, co nemůže uspokojit.
Právě tohle je cesta odšičování.
Všechny podmíněné věci jsou neuspokojivé.
Když je toho moudře kapánu, člověk se oprostí od toho, co nemůže uspokojit.
Právě tohle je cesta očišťovaný.
Všechny podmíněné věci a ono nepodmíněné jsou bezpodstatní.
Když je toho moudře kapánu, člověk se oprostí od toho, co nemůže uspokojit.
Právě tohle je cesta očišťování.
Existuje to, co není zrozené, co neumírá, co není stvořené a není podmíněné.
Utočiště, přístav a domov.
Dokonalá spokojenost a klid.
Jako oceán má jen jednou chuť a to slanou,
Tak Nibbana má jenom jednou chuť, chuť osvobození.
Základní vlastností všech složených věcí je jejich rozpad.
Pracujte plně na svém osvobození.
A teď přijímáme předsevzetí, že projdeme všem sedmý dní toho kursu.
Sádu, sádu, sádu.
Takže uděláme nějaké sedání a znovu udělám jen trochu představu.
Uvědomíte si, že je vaše postura příjemná.
Svědčte se, že vaše poloha je příjemná.
Tak krátké sezéní šprácmi.
Přesvědčte se, že vaše tělo je dobře energizováno páteří.
Žádného napětí krku.
Uvolněte čelo, ramena,
čersti,
Když se vaše tělo cítí pohodlně a energizováno, nasmějte pozornost na dech.
Použijte označování, abyste udrželi vaši pozornost pevnou.
falling, touching, zvedání, klesání, dotýkání.
Jestliže se mysl zatvulá, uvidíte si to, rozpoznajte to a přeneste pozornost zpátky na dech.
A můžete i otevřít oči trochu, jen abychom vytvořili světlo.
Když se cítíme vzpomínanými na vzpomínání, cožkoliv vzpomíná na naše představování, v podmíně vědomosti, to se stane objektem,
Jak byli jsme usazeni na tom dechu, cokoliv vstoupí do pole naší pozornosti, tak je to objekt pozorovat, pozorování, cítění, k prožitku.
Jestli se mysl zatoulá, rozpoznajte to, mějte jasno, co mysl dělá a přineste pozornost spátky i v dechu.
Chcete rozpalý vnavení, rozvedněte páteř,
Můžete vidět, jak vše, co zažíváme, jednoduše vzniká a zase odchází.
Když se mysl toulá, rozpoznejte to a pozornost přeneste zpátky na vnitř.
Když se cítíte rovnaveně, ospalí, otáhněte páteř, staněte dělí.
Vše, co zakoušíme, je vznikání a odchází.
Jak toto můžu být já?
Jestliže se mysl to volá, rozpoznějte to a přineste pozornost zpátky na dech.
Jestliže jste ospalí a bůh neumí, vám rozjedněte páteř.
Můžeme si všimnout, jak je ten svět nás rozdělený na věci,
Máme rádi ty, které nemáme, a ty, které máme rádi, tak jimi, jestli zaobíráme, ty, které nemáte, nemáte, tak odsunejte.
Umožněte jakékoliv vzpomínce na nové sezení, aby přišla do mysli.
Měli jste se označování?
Nebo jste se nechali, nebo jste byli líní?
Měli jste
Problémy s označováním?
Pomohlo vám to?
Udržovat pozornost z okamžiku na okamžik?